i want to look with you at some
record-setting clips of a new donald
trump interview donald trump was
interviewed and to call it an interview
is kind of weird because it was just a
fluff piece
ronna mcdaniel the rnc chair who i guess
now has a podcast she interviewed donald
trump and donald trump i'm going to play
a clip for you in which i believe in 12
seconds he tells four lies it it's it's
record setting quite literally um but
just to give you a sense of this bizarre
interview here is ronna mcdaniel
talking about how great trump has been
to women i i know guys i know thank you
for what you're doing thank you for
being out there i just have two fun
things i want to say to you this is
going to be fun guys we're about to have
fun and
you're such a wonderful person you've
been so great to women thank you for
what you're doing
um
trump's been accused of harassment
through assault
of 46 women by 46 women
um and she says you you've just been so
fantastic for women now here's the clip
this is a 17 second clip
ronna mcdaniel speaks for five seconds
so trump only speaks for 12 seconds and
he tells four lies
see if you can spot him okay here's it
it'll be like a game show dur and you
saved hundreds of thousands if not
millions of lives with that well you
know we had in 1917
100 million people died i think we would
have had the same thing so we did
something that was incredible we did it
in less than nine months and it was
supposed to take anywhere from five to
twelve years
so did you spot the four lies or
misstatements there
first
he only spoke 12 seconds more like 11
but the math is easier if we say 12. um
he said that there was a pandemic in
1917 there wasn't it was in 1918. he
keeps telling that lie we don't know why
he's sticking with it
number two he says that if it weren't
for the vaccines he developed 100
million people would have died of covet
there is no serious estimate that
suggests that
number three he says he's the one who
got the vaccines done that's also untrue
all he did was agree to pre-purchase
some vaccines which any american
president would have done in this
situation and number four
he says it it were not for him it would
have taken five to twelve years to
develop the vaccine that's not true with
the vaccine that you build from scratch
that was historically the case
mrna technology has been in development
for decades and the whole point of mrna
technology is you can much more quickly
sequence a virus and develop a vaccine
in about a year which is exactly what
happened
four lies
in 12 seconds
unbelievable
couple other clips from this interview
here is trump saying
stopping nordstream was the worst thing
to ever happen to russia history buffs
will know that's not true
there was never anybody tougher on
russia than i was now that's a lie also
and i would say that putin would if he
was being honest he would say that
the sanctions i put on i was the one
that ended north stream exactly there
was never anybody even close i mean
nordstrom to them nordstrom 2 was the
biggest thing nobody ever even heard of
it until i came along complained
and then i shut it down
and there was never anything so big that
happened to russia shutting down
nordstrom two and then now uh russia uh
the you know the soviet union
lost 27 million people during world war
ii
and then when the ussr collapsed one of
the uh
just absolute and total economic
disaster i i think it's a bit
exaggerated to say nordstrom 2 was the
worst and biggest thing that happened
there and then lastly trump uh says the
following about how president xi reacted
to biden pulling out of afghanistan
i think that's actually a big reason why
the
problem you have with ukraine i think
when putin and washi and when kim
jong-un and when the iranians are
watching that the iranian leaders
i think they saw what happened in
afghanistan and i think that gave them
a new sense of power and dignity
[Laughter]
what is he even it's a word salad it's a
word salad she got a sense of dignity
from biden leaving afghanistan it's out
of this world guys it's completely and
totally meaningless but notably
four lies
in 12 seconds in that earlier clip
that's one lie every three three seconds
that actually
i would have if you said david you have
12 seconds to tell four lies
you need real uh linguistic efficiency
to even make that happen and trump does
it without even thinking about it we'll
have these clips on our instagram find
them at david pakman show we'll take a
quick break and be right back
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar that's why
you should check out our long time
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar
14 grams of protein and only four net
carbs so it's perfect if you're doing
low carb or keto or if like me you just
try to limit your sugar intake you can
build your own variety pack with flavors
like cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman